he's great i don't hate him i hate
draymond i hate clay i don't hate steph
he didn't say [ __ ] word i actually
said one thing to him he turned like
you're gonna have to do it yourself he'd
look because i know i am and he did and
alpha bro what did you think about the
uh [ __ ] you draymond champ that is pg
maybe g he plays along with it that's
his vibe that's fine and i also think if
players talk back you can talk to them
like a couple scrubs and playing the
refs he's like sit down meanwhile
iguodala came out he's yelling at the
dude he's like they've never seen a
black person before well now you can
engage with the fans
as long as you keep it towards the
player you don't go family it's not
threat you're not touching but [ __ ] you
draymond but i do think people cross the
line talking about like bronze kid and
[ __ ] yeah let's just be honest everyone
likes it both ways wait are you saying
lebron's a hypocrite bro i've been a
lebron hater to like for a long time i
have an article 27 reasons lebron james
is the antichrist